look I know what you're thinking show us
your tits a few years ago I worked as a
chiropractors assistant she told me that
there was a hypnotherapy college yes
there's a hypnotherapy college and they
had a program where if you had a
traumatic experience happen in your life
you could sign up for free sessions with
a certified hypnotherapist so I applied
and I got in and I spent the next four
or five months
seeing this hypnotherapist once a week
for half year I come literally what he
taught me was how to measure how much I
was investing in my own success and the
method was kind of like balancing a
checkbook balancing a checkbook uh now I
say it was like balancing a checkbook
because the dollar amounts are all
fictional so what you would do is you'd
price out hours worth of your time an
hour of reading 100 bucks an hour
reading 25 a night of stand-up 500
dollars because that gave me a shit ton
of anxiety so after establishing this
key or this legend of sorts I had to
keep track every day of exactly where my
time went and I would pay myself every
night it feels like it's mentally making
it rain it used to be that my ambitions
would exceed my ability to execute or
like my willingness to work hard but
this activity changed something because
it wasn't like these were intangible
hours of experience they were right
there on the paper and they were
associated with my favorite thing dolla
dolla sign's y'all does hypnosis really
work or what hypnotherapy sessions go
like this I went into a small office I
sat down in front of my hypnotherapist
we talked for 10 minutes this is what
went on last week this is what I'm
feeling this is what I'd like to work on
he goes okay okay write some stuff down
he takes a little pendant I don't
remember if it was like a clock or like
the thing with the illusionist thing on
it but it would tick talk back and forth
in front of man I would have to follow
it with only my eyes don't remember the
logic of why it was only my eyes
something about it triggered something
in
brain or it opens up your brain or you
becoming alien then I would sit back
close my eyes relax my body and he would
basically recite customized positive
affirmations so if we were talking about
my anxiety would stand up he would
smoothly say things like I look forward
to making people laugh I am a bright
light on the stage I am afraid of
nothing things like this does
hypnotherapy work I honestly don't know
I'm Anna Akana
you stay awesome very awesome you're
feeling very awesome on the count of
three you're going to close your eyes
put your fingers on the keyboard go to
your favorite porn site one
action
Hey